bon je pense que nous sommes à l'antenne
alors vite votre affaire qui peut vous
intéresser monsieur brand c'est la
sphère du à bordeaux on apprend que
quelques familles de déportés on porte
plainte contre monsieur pas pour le
canard enchaîné avait importé quelques
révélations sur l'attitude de monsieur
maurice papon lorsqu'il était secrétaire
général de la préfecture de bordeaux
pendant l'occupation de la france par
les troupes allemandes pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale or on apprend
que plusieurs familles de déportés de
bordeaux décide de porter plainte contre
lui
monsieur papa était encore au chili où
vient d'être reçu par le gouvernement
pinochet maîtres boulangers interrogé
par les journalistes de fr3 répond et
explique pourquoi cette plainte et cette
action entreprise par ses clients 40 ans
après écoutons maître boulanger
interrogé par nos confrères fr3 bordeaux
ne sait pas si maurice papon était
intouchable et ce n'est pas moi à me
prononcer sur ce point là je pense que
d'une part il ya eu un défaut
d'information c'est à dire que les
familles en question n'ont pas su
exactement qu'elle avait été son rôle
deuxièmement il se peut que certaines
familles et sue et qu'elle ait pensé qu'
on n'attaquait pas comme cela quelqu'un
qui a été quand même préfet de police de
paris entre 1958 et 1968 si mes
souvenirs sont exacts en dix ans qui a
été député qui a été président de
commission à l'assemblée nationale qui a
été pour finir ministre du budget dans
le dernier gouvernement barre peut-être
que ces familles ont
on pensait qu'on ne pouvait pas
s'attaquer à un homme public aussi
important et il faut être le supposé
aussi influent et puis je vous dire
quand même quelque chose et c'est quand
même l'élément essentiel à mes yeux il
ne restait pas grand monde en moi j'ai
en mémoire une interview de monsieur
papon après les révélations du canard
enchaîné au monde
jean-marc théoleyre l'avait interviewé
je crois que c'est le monde du 8 mai
1981 et lui posant la question qu'est ce
que vous pensez monsieur pas prendre de
ces accusations et de vos accusateurs et
monsieur papon avait répondu ce ces gens
là mes accusateurs
ce qu'ils oublient de dire c'est que
j'ai aussi sauvé des juifs ce aussi me
paraît terrible